for memories to form free functions have
to take place
acquiring learning or experiencing
something new
consolidating this is where the memories
become stable
and finally recall the ability to recall
that information in the future
[Music]
can juggling really increase brain
activity
german researchers divided 24
non-jugglers to two groups and asked one
group to practice juggling for three
months they found that those who didn't
juggle showed no difference in brain
activity over the test period
but those who juggled an increase in
gray matter in two areas of the
hippocampus
and neocortex
parts of the brain involved in memory
visual and motor activity
the brain is like a muscle and needs
exercise
to exercise your memory
you don't necessarily have to learn a
new physical skill like juggling
[Music]
juarez qualcaire cosa dezde aplende un
nuevo idioma hasta mercola in unh
[Music]
a memory palace is where you imagine a
place where you can store information
memory experts use this trick a lot to
remember number sequences or even a
whole deck of cards
let's say you have a simple list of
things you want to buy step one
start at your door and go anti-clockwise
around your room labeling each item one
to seven in order
step two
in my room my bed is the first object so
i would place the first item i want to
remember
buying an apple for example on my bed
step three create a visual image and
exaggerate it in some way to make it
more memorable if the first item is an
apple picture a big purple apple
crushing your bed
repeat the process
until every piece of information is
associated to an item in your memory
palace
[Music]
during sleep your body rests although
your brain is busily processing
information from the day
to form memories
[Music]
[Music]
people who recall their dreams improve
their memory
and are more creative
try keeping a dream diary of some sort
just a notebook and pen
so you can write down or sketch as much
as you can remember
as soon as you wake up
so there you have it acquiring
consolidating and finally recall simple
tips to improve your memory
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video